hello this is the start of a new series
about common C++ compiling errors this
is intended to help new people get over
the roadblock of having the pile of
errors they don't understand some of
them are pretty simple to fix and I want
to show you and you probably know about
the title of this video about how to
overcome the common redecoration error
people get an error that says this
variable is being read Eclair diff
already defined here and when I show you
how to in general fix that so I'm gonna
create the scenario first of all bear
with me a moment I've got an empty
folder here we're gonna create all my
files and I'm just going to create this
this error so say we have a main if you
always do and say we have I don't know
some kind of header that has some stuff
for us
maybe utilities we call it utilities of
stuff that we just kind of want to have
available to our project to use all the
time then say we have a class that we're
also going to to use that goes with it
um for sake of example we'll call this
one a a bank a bank class so we're gonna
have the header and the object that goes
with it so create those four files now
we probably also want to make file just
to make our compiling a little easier so
these are all empty by default we'll
just kind of created them so we're gonna
go ahead and just populate them real
quick should just take a few minutes
you
okay continuing on with the example so
we have our main clues both these we're
not using them yet I'm just kind of
building something that shows an example
of this error case and talking about
we built this Bank class with some some
functions that are in the header there's
nothing in the bank does CP so they're
all defined here in the header then we
have a utilities which I've put in one
function than those utilities dot H I
think I spelled it wrong yeah I missed
an i/o I'll fix that later don't worry
about it so that's in the header so in
the main we won't include utilities in
this bank dot h1 to include utilities
and I think I need to spell it right so
let me do that real quick
of course we have a makefile which we
should do something with you know I'm
going to do this the easy way
file all right so this should handle
pretty much everything chorus I don't
wanna have to edit this make file so I'm
gonna move my source
do a new folder long source put all
these in there that way this make file
to calm and okay this way when we do
make run and see there's a run which
doesn't make all in it it runs whatever
we built the run macro when's their
target will leave it change me for now
cuz it doesn't matter too much but what
I'm gonna do here okay to mainly show
you this error we're gonna look at this
function which is defined in a header so
when you include it one of your one of
your C++ files that's going to turn into
an object which will be any of these CPP
it builds this function in that object
now if you build it into two different
objects if you have two different
objects that are building the same one
that's when you get the the duplicate
error catching a little lag here on my
machine alright so maybe you'll want to
say okay we've got the utilities and
credit include we also want to just
print lowest allowed which we'll use
this function
to print Louis laude one now this should
all work fine because I've only included
it in one place you need to finish
declaring our class properly so let's
make this fullscreen there goes a says
hello world says well is the loud that's
great so it works now where we can
introduce the problem the duplicate
error is we try to do this somewhere
else like let's try to have this bank
dulce also do it so it already includes
utilities this is going to bank del H
which will also include utilities
because it's in here retro actively
include and we say we want to have avoid
print and lowest and rather then define
it here we're going to [ __ ] define this
one over in bank does CP so we'll build
over into this object
this but what we're gonna have this do
since this already includes utilities is
have it call to lunch on utilities
lowest allowed oh my gosh I'm catching
so much like how laggy is this video
we're gonna be even gonna be releasable
okay so that's what its gonna do is it's
gonna use this function which means it
should try to build it into here as well
and into here since we're using here and
we should get the double include error
okay include iostream here and we'll do
clear on this clear thanks bro
and here we have multiple definition of
Trent lowest allowed first to find here
this is the error I'm talking about this
multiple definition and this is how you
create it you have a header with no
associated object directly like there's
no utilities dot CPP so it's building
into wherever you include it and if you
included it into multiple objects that
tries to build a twice and duplicates so
one way to fix this is to make this
defined somewhere else
so for sake of example cut that I'm just
going to make this a header and then I'm
going to make another let me go in the
source and I'm going to make a file
called utilities I can spell it
C++ okay
and now we should have that file
you go into my folder there it is we're
go ahead and open it Jeanne as well and
we're just going to of course include
abilities so who knows about it better
for it
and here we're just going to define it
focused allow catching a little back
here so what happens now
first we want to do a make cleaning to
get rid of all our objects oh wow
actually is clean and pleats are stuff
I'm gonna do another make run and this
time we do not get the duplication error
we don't get the multiple definition cuz
it's only defined in once by and that's
its associated CPP file so there you go
that's how you avoid the double include
error from your headers that's one of
the ways there are other ways not gonna
get into those because they get a little
more complicated but the easiest way is
to just make an Associated CP file that
defines it rather than having it defined
in your header so if you define in your
header just to recap you to find in a
header it builds into whatever C++ file
you use it in but if you only make it a
declaration in the header and define it
somewhere else
it only builds in that one object and
doesn't give you the multiple build so
it's only it's only in this object
before I did introduce the utilities up
CVP it was trying it was basically
building on both of these and running in
the duplication error so since we didn't
want that we just do a whole nother
another one so there you go I hope you
guys found this informative and look out
for episode two will talk about more
common c++ errors don't forget to
subscribe like this video and all that
good stuff I appreciate any support I
can get this is a rather new channel
still I'd like it to
continue growing and to get a community
and hopefully we can get more people
interested in coding and I'm trying to
make videos where it can make it fun too
and coding is a rather important thing
in our day and age and a lot of people
plan intimidating and I can see why it
is rather frustrating sometimes so I'll
see you next time goodbye